with rise of iron destiny feels like a
game that's within reach of fresh ideas
but can't quite escape its own past
there are moments of exhilaration
throughout the newest expansion and a
few inspiring missions remain rooted in
my memory but as Bungie shooter Wade's
into its third year a sense of fatigue
has risen to the surface
Destiny's exhaustion is beginning to
show this may not make sense to you but
it took your fight to remind me that
immortality is not the same as
invincibility from a story standpoint
rise of iron follows our Guardians as
they assist lord saladin one of the last
remaining members of the iron Lords and
his fight against Siva a nanobot plague
that all but exterminated his group
years before present events at its
outset rise of iron displays a confident
sense of character with Lord of the
Rings inspirations in game of throne
aesthetics to boo but that wears thin
soon thereafter Destiny's new campaign
lasts for about 90 minutes and while it
does a decent job of setting up the
expansions late-game missions and public
events the plot serves only to introduce
us to new quest givers in areas of
interests any narrative promised the
opening moments displays soon fades the
campaign's final boss battle may be
thrilling as it encourages frantic melee
combat against an onslaught of enemies
but the short trip it takes to get there
as forgettable as a major destiny
expansion though rise of iron also
brings additional cooperative strikes
public events player-versus-player
options a new social space a new patrol
zone and a six player raid but much of
rise of iron's content is taken directly
from Destiny's first two years and given
a fresh coat of paint
yes Siva infected enemies bring new
dangers to firefights and existing
bosses have changed their combat
strategy to make things feel just fresh
enough but the destiny grind is more
apparent here than ever
I'm waiting through strikes I've played
dozens of times before the wretched I
strike rise of iron truly new
cooperative venture is one of the
aforementioned shining moments but it's
surrounded by vapid echoes of the past
supremacy rise of iron's player versus
player content follows suit the new
supremacy game-mode requires you to pick
up fallen orbs from slain enemies not
granting you full credit for a kill
until you do so their glory goes while
supremacy does lure you out of your
comfort zone with enticing scenarios the
experience is only a slight variation on
the classic deathmatch formula as with
rise of iron's campaign supremacy feels
uninspired rise of iron's maps are well
designed combining close quarters
battles and long range engagements with
seeming ease but these maps just set the
stage for a new mode that doesn't pull
its own creative weight remind me never
to take you lightly Guardian Double Down
you
shame
yes three down look at them fools I
can't believe what I'm seeing
rise of iron's redundant content is a
shame too considering the moments of
greatness that it does deliver the
questline to obtain the newest version
of Gjallarhorn destinies now mythical
rocket launcher culminates a massive
battle the likes of which Bungie hasn't
created since its Halo days archons
forged the expansion's new public event
space plays host to chaotic battles
between a possible nine players in a
variety of alien bosses the sheer
spectacle of these skirmishes combines
with Destiny's mechanical fluidity to
create some of the shooters finest
moments to date this rings true in rise
of iron's wrath of the Machine raid the
trek pits you and five other players
against an array of enemies and a bevy
of complex scenarios that don't use boss
battles and hordes of enemies just as
crutches
while these elements are present rather
the Machine demands that you rethink
what a boss fight can be without
spoiling too much one section of the
raid asks you not to just battle a
massive enemy but use it as
transportation to wrath of the machines
final encounter is also one of those
shining moments I keep coming back to
despite the difficulty you'll encounter
it's a stunning combination of teamwork
survival techniques and combat tactics
as well as using the expansions
pervasive seva against itself that will
carry your squad through but the raid is
the sparkling light at the end of an
often dreary tunnel I spent dozens of
hours slogging through familiar strikes
uninspired new crucible content and a
patrol zone that felt like a retread not
an adventure I found myself playing more
for the new gear and light levels for
the progress that is than the actual
enjoyment
approach as an expansion that revamped
how destiny actually played last years
the taken King was a major step forward
for the shooter but rise of iron feels
just like the other foot catching up to
rest firmly in place it feels timid it
feels safe
it feels like the last remaining breath
before the possible sequel as if destiny
is standing still and waiting for
inspiration to arrive rather than going
out to find it the iron Lords are gone
but our fight is far from over
[Music]
[Music]